I became a drug addict when I was about
15 years old about a year after my dad
died and I was addicted to drugs for 14
years
during that time when you're an addict
you're living against conscience
and when you're living and I never you
know I was always trying to get off the
drugs never able to but I never felt
good about what I was doing
and I'm
and when you're living against conscious
you kind of push God to the peripheries
of your life so
I'll call me he
get recedes and get smaller and then
when I
um
when I got sober
I knew that
I had a couple of experiences one is
that I had a friend of my brothers one
of my brothers who died of this disease
of addiction
I had a good friend who had used to take
drugs with us
and he became a Mooney so he he became a
follower of Reverend son young Moon
and he's at that point his compulsion he
had the same kind of compulsion that I
had and yet it was completely removed
from him
and so and he used to come and hang out
with us
but he would not want to take drugs even
if I was taking him right in front of
him he was I he was immune to it he'd
become impervious to that impulse
and um I when I was in the when I first
got sober I was I knew that I did not
want to be the kind of person who was
you know waking up every day in white
knuckling sobriety and just you know
trying to resist through willpower and
by the way
I had
um I had iron willpower as a kid I gave
up candy for Len when I was 12 and I
didn't need it again until I was in
college
I gave up um I gave up desserts the next
year for Lent and I didn't ever eat
another dessert until I was in college
and I was trying to bulk up for a rugby
and for sports
so um I felt like I could do anything
with my willpower but somehow
this particular thing you know the
addiction
was completely impervious to it and I it
was cunning bathing baffling
incomprehensible I could not understand
why I couldn't just say no and then
never do it again like I did with
everything else
um and um
so I was living against conscience and I
and I I thought about this guy
and I you know reflecting my own
prejudices at that time in my life I was
I said to myself
I didn't want to be I didn't want to be
like a drug addict who was wanting a
drug all the time and just not being
able to do it
I wanted to completely realign my my
myself
so that I was somebody who got up every
day and just didn't want to take drugs
never thought of them you know I guess
the wife and children and went to work
and was never thought about drugs the
whole day
and I knew that people throughout
history had done that you know I had
read the lives of the Saints I knew
Saint Augustine had been very very
dissolute youth
and and you know I had the spiritual
realignment transformation I knew the
same thing had happened to Saint Paul
you know Damascus the same thing had
happened in Saint Francis Saint Francis
also had a
at a dissolute and fun loving Youth and
and had you know had this this deep
spiritual realignment and I I knew that
that happened to people throughout
history
and I thought that's what I needed you
know something like that
I had the example of this random mine
and I used to think about him and I
would think this again reflects the bias
and that you know
probably the meanness of myself at that
time but I said I'd rather be dead than
be a Mooney
but I wish I somehow could distill
that power that he got without becoming
a religious nuisance
and um and at that time I picked up a
book
um by Carl Jung called synchronicity and
Young
he was a psychiatrist his contemporary
of Freud's he was a I'm afraid was his
mentor and and Freud wanted him to be
his replacement but Freud was not about
atheists
and young was a deeply spiritual man he
had these very intense and genuine
spiritual experiences from when he was a
little boy from at least three years old
that he remembers biography is
fascinating about him because he
remembers him with such a detail
and um he uh
he was he had written he was always he
was interesting to me because he was
very faithful scientist and I consider
myself a science-based person from when
I was little
and yet he had this spiritual Dimension
to him
which infused all of his thinking and
really I think made him you know it is
the Branded his his form of of recovery
or
um of treatment
and he thought that he had this
experiment experience that he describes
in this book
where he's sitting up on the third and
one of the biggest sanitariums in Europe
in Zurich
and he was sitting up on the third floor
of this building
and he's talking to a patient who had
who was talking describing her dream to
him
and the fulcrum of that dream was a
scarab beetle which was an insect that
is not is a very very uncommon if at all
in northern Europe but it's a
common figure in the iconography of of
Egypt and the hieroglyphics on the on
the walls of the pyramids Etc
and um
he and he while he was talking to her he
heard this bing bing bing on the window
behind him and he didn't want to turn
around to take his attention off her but
finally he does it he's an exasperation
he turns around he throws up the window
and a scarab beetle flies and lands in
his head and he shows it to the woman
and he says is this what you were
thinking of is this what you were
dreaming about and he he was struck by
that experience experience which was
similar to other experiences he's had
like that and that's what synchronicity
means it's a
it's a an instant a coincidence you know
and like if so if you're if you're
talking with somebody about somebody
that you haven't thought about in 20
years and that person calls on the phone
that's synchronicity oh and he believed
it was a way that God intervened in our
lives that broke all the all the rules
of nature that he had set up the rules
of physics the rules of mathematics or
you know to reach in and sort of tap us
on the shoulder and say I'm here
and um and so he tried to reproduce that
in a clinical setting
and he would put one guy in one room and
another guy in another room and have
them flip guards and then guess what the
other guy had flipped
and he believed that if he could beat
the laws of chance laws of mathematics
and he would approve the existence of
his of an unnatural law a supernatural
law and that was the first step to
proving the existence of a god
he never succeeds in doing it but he
says in the book
um even though I can't prove using
empirical and scientific tools the
existence of a god
I can show through anecdotal evidence
having seen thousands of patients come
from this institution that people who
believe in God get better faster and
that the recovery is more enduring than
people who don't
and for me hearing that was more
impactful than if he had claimed that he
had to proved the existence of a God
because I would not believe that
but I I was already in a mindset where I
would have done anything I could to
improve my chances of never having to
take drugs again by even one percent and
if believing in God
was going to help me whether there's a
God up there or not believing in one
itself had the power to help me I was
going to do that so then the question is
how do you start believing in something
that you can't see or smell or hear or
touch or taste or acquire with your
senses
and young provides the formula for that
and he says he says act as if you fake
it to him again
and so that's you know what I started
doing I just started pretending there
was a god watching me all the time and
kind of life was a series of deaths and
each there was a bunch of moral
decisions that I had to make every day
and each one
you know these were all just little
things that I did but each one now for
me at a moral Dimension like when I um
you know when the alarm goes off do I
lay in bed for an extra 10 minutes with
my handle and thoughts or do I jump
right out of bed
do I do I make my bad most important
decision of the day do I hang up the
towels you know do I um do I when I go
into the closet and pull out my blue
jeans and a bunch of those wire hangers
fall on the ground do I shut the door
and say I'm too much I'm too important
to do that that's somebody else's job or
not and so
I put the water in the ice tray before I
put in the freezer do I put the shopping
cart back in the you know place that
it's supposed to go in the parking lot
of the Safeway
and if I make a whole bunch of those
choices right
that
um I maintain myself in a posture of
surrender which keeps me open to the
power of to my higher power to my God
and when that when I do those things
right
um when I you know so much about
addiction is about abuse of power abuse
of
all of us have some power whether it's
our you know good looks or whether it's
uh
you know connections or education or our
family or whatever
and there's always attemption a
temptation to use those to fill fulfill
self-will
and the challenge is how do you use
those always to serve instead God's will
and you know the good of our community
and that
to me is kind of the struggle and but
when I do that
I feel I feel God's power coming through
me and that I can do things are much
more effective as a human being
that that gnawing you know uh anxiety
that I lived with for so many years and
my God that I it's gone
and that um I can kind of like
put down the oars and always the sale
and you know and the wind takes me and I
can I can see the evidence of it in my
life
and you know the big thing for you know
to Temptation for me is that
um
when all these good things start
happening in my life and the cash and
prizes start flowing in
you know how do I maintain that posture
of surrender how do I say you surrender
then when on my inclination is to say to
God thanks God I got it from here yeah
and drive the car off the cliff again
and uh
so you know I had a spiritual awakening
and my desire for drugs and alcohol was
lifted miraculously
uh and it to me it was as much a miracle
as if I had if I'd been able to walk on
water because I had tried everything
earnestly sincerely and honestly for a
decade to try to stop and I could not do
it under my own power and then all of a
sudden it was lifted effortlessly and um
you know so I saw that evidence
uh early evidence of God in my life and
I'm of the power
and um and I see it now you know every
day of my life